pommes golden pâte brisée caramel
d'heure de normandie l'essentiel et rien
d'autre c'est le secret de la tarte
tatin de claudette fourni depuis trente
ans un savoir faire qu'elle est venue
démontrer à l'occasion d'un concours de
cuisine amateur organisé à lamotte
beuvron la tat aupoint attaque avec tout
un tas d'ingrédients des légumes de la
viande et puis tout ça pour moi ça c'est
plus de la tatin la tatin pour moi c'est
les pommes
cette recette claudette la découvre lors
de son installation à lamotte beuvron à
cette époque elle épluche toutes les
sources d'informations possibles sur le
destin hors du commun des soeurs tatin
depuis la passion pour leur art ne l'a
jamais quittée durant l'automne elle en
prépare deux fois par mois
à dessert fabuleux épique elle a porté
tout le monde après le tour de main
c'est pas la renverser par terre à faut
vraiment à la mecque
à chacun sa définition de la tarte idéal
pour tiny mauclair pas besoin de se
plonger dans les manuels de cuisine tout
est une question d'instinct
je vise à lui rendu après en fait c'est
comme ça qu'il prépare mes plats
comment comment ça va sortir est ce que
il faut que ça me plaise déjà sa marque
de fabrique
reprendre un classique et ajouter sa
touche personnelle ici du safran diluée
dans du beurre tout ce qu'on connaît pas
j'ai envie d'essayer pourra changer
d'aidé de l'ordinaire pourquoi ça fait
vraiment partie de votre personnalisés
exactement moi je suis quelqu'un je
m'élance je fais plein décès j'adore
cuisiner donc je m'en lasserais si je
fais tout le temps la même chose une
certitude pour ces deux passionnés de
cuisine elles ne pourront jamais se
lasser de la tarte tatin